I'm laughing I shouldn't be loud when
I'm talking about hemorrhoids Oh too
many gross words together
enos filling with blood poop burning in
the [ __ ] okay do not be eating
anything while you watch today's video
anyone I'm a be sharp welcome to another
edition of toilet talk where I get up
close and personal with your porcelain
throne help you answer your dirtiest and
darkest secrets today I've got a
question from straining Sally Dear Abby
I have never had trouble with my bowels
until I got pregnant and that was some
serious pregnancy constipation then
while delivering my daughter I pushed so
hard I was left not only with some
brutal tearing OH
but a pretty horrible case of
hemorrhoids one of my lowest points in
my life was when I allowed myself to
sneak a peek of what was going on back
there and I was convinced that there was
a bum growing inside my bum it was
mildly traumatic forget about losing
weight what can I eat help me get my ass
back sign streaming Sally time to get
personal lovelies let's talk about your
anus
so hemorrhoids are essentially swollen
veins inside the anal canal they can
happen outside the anal canal or they
can happen inside the anal canal how
many times can we say anal we will see
that'll be the big question for today
folks well they're definitely pretty
common and can be a little bit painful
they're usually not too serious so some
of the common symptoms of hemorrhoids
are bleeding during bowel movements
pitching and rectal pain so whenever too
much pressure is put on our veins both
in our pelvic and rectal area
hemorrhoids can occur and there's a few
main reasons why number one sitting on
the toilet too long when we sit on the
toilet for too long the increased
pressure to move stool over time can
cause the veins in the tissue to swell
and stress which in turn can cause
hemorrhoids number two constipation and
diarrhea when we're not regular the
increased pressure and straining on our
veins in her anal canal can cause
hemorrhoids and finally pregnancy and
labor so it's very common in the last 6
months of pregnancy for women to
experience a lot of pressure on some of
the blood vessels in the pelvic region
and then during labor and delivery when
women are pushing a baby out that
draining motion and that pushing can
often worsen or create hemorrhoids so
first of all why do you do about
hemorrhoids so there are some
over-the-counter medications and
procedures that you can look into if
it's an external hemorrhoid situation
sometimes getting an over counter point
mint can help reduce the pain or the
itching and a stool software can make it
easier for you to have a bowel movement
so that you're not straining further and
exacerbating the hemorrhoids if it's an
internal hemorrhoid a doctor sometimes
needs to kind of go in with a simple
procedure to help reduce the blood flow
to the hemorrhoid so that it can shrink
and go away number two pump up that
fiber so fiber doesn't wonders for the
body it is particularly important for
regularity so you want to focus on
getting your 25 to 38 grams of fiber
every single day also if you're not
quite used to getting a lot of fiber in
your diet you want to introduce it
slowly so your body can adjust over time
so some great sources of fiber conclude
in your diet are things like whole
grains like whole grain pastas and
breads and quinoa as well as beans
legumes and of course lots of fruits and
vegetables with the skin on and of
course if you cannot get a from your
diet you can also try including in a
fiber supplement number three avoid
constipation causing foods so you want
to cut back on some of the
ultra-processed foods in your diet like
candies chips crackers cakes things like
that often these kinds of foods are
devoid of any fiber which we just talked
about and they should be kind of reduced
when you're trying to treat your
hemorrhoids number four making sure
you're staying hydrated so water
actually works in conjunction with fiber
to help things move along so you want to
make sure that you're getting in lots of
fluids throughout your day number five
take a bath getting into a nice pool of
warm soothing water is a great way to
help relieve some of the pain and
discomfort of hemorrhoids number six
exercise keeping yourself active is a
great way to keep yourself regular and
your bowels moving so make sure you're
getting in at least thirty minutes of
activity every day and number seven
keep your smart phone out of the
washroom so not only is this a hygiene
thing but smartphones tend to keep us on
the toilet for a lot longer
and there's a new clinical trial
actually happening right now that is
looking at the incidence of hemorrhoids
and smartphone use in the washroom so I
say keep your smartphones and your
tablets out of the bathroom and focus on
the business at hand well Sally I hope
that answered some of your questions on
what to do about your hemorrhoids if
your symptoms do not resolve themselves
within a week I definitely recommend
following up with your doctor I hope you
guys all enjoyed this video if you did
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with some of your
burning toilet talk related questions
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
I'm so sorry about [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]